[Music]
a royal rendition and a well-wishing
crowd in windsor
the queen's 96th birthday played out by
the band of the cold stream guards
horses led the way in hyde park for the
gun salutes
the king's troop royal horse artillery
firing the first rounds
and the celebratory salutes echoed in
edinburgh
the queen's spending her birthday
fuss-free at sandringham looking well
and relaxed as she was driven through
the estate
she'll be up there for a week and of
course the great excitement for her is
that she's very near the sandringham
stud and she can see her horses and any
of the little fellas being that have
been born recently and things and that's
what she really loves doing so she'll be
very very happy
we know the queen loves her horses
buckingham palace released birthday
photos this one taken last month
and here aged two in 1928 a toddler
princess elizabeth
perhaps she would have enjoyed this a
special edition jubilee barbie doll
maybe not but there was support from her
family tweeting messages and posting
photos another milestone marked
the queen keeping low key away from the
crowds and a chance to rest before the
pomp and pageantry of her platinum
jubilee laura bundock sky news